posting a deep fake as a gag
totally fine so in the context of being
like Trump is Buddy Buddy with fauci and
this is how we see it I'd be like that's
kind of dirty
but I wouldn't be I probably forget
about it right away to produce an ad
where you write real life Trump and then
show it very briefly very quickly along
with real images
the intent is is is is is is palpable
it's Matt it's visible
if they just posted a single image you
could be like oh look that text is fake
the White House emblem says it's not a
real whims it said those aren't words
it's gibberish you could see that right
because like for some reason AI cannot
get texted right well because it's it's
text is code it's like writing meaning
into images it can get sure can you
imagine that something like the like the
alphabet in the English language could
be they should work on that pretty
easily programmed it